okay it is fully on fire
[Music]
hey I need to go after the game plan I'm
gonna go ahead and say I use all these
items all right I feel like all of these
now are meant to make me think I need
them and I don't need them I was just
gonna say I could just drink it but it
is I haven't even had like this yet am I
allowed to make this evaporate does that
count that's gonna put all the
toothpicks on here and maybe that would
create a barrier but I don't think
there's enough I don't think this is
gonna do anything it's impossible is it
this doesn't make any sense this looks
like it's gonna work
not at all nope
Oh
oh shoot it isn't fire don't quite know
what to do next I don't want to light
anything I think this is a really bad
idea I really don't know how to do this
and it makes me mad I think I'm done
[Music]
yeah I mean doesn't do anything
[Music]
you light it on fire I'm not gonna burn
myself son of a [ __ ] it's hot it it's
really hot holy [ __ ] oh it's hot Oh
perfect there's like fire cupping you
know that like Michael Phelps did that
last year at the Olympics I have a trick
now science is crazy
Bill Nye was right
[Music]